हेलो एवरीवन एंड फर्स्ट ऑफ ऑल वेरी गुड
इवनिंग टू ऑल। अगर सबको मेरी आवाज सुनाई
दे रही है तो प्लीज चैट में रिप्लाई
कीजिए।
गाइज अगर आपको मेरी आवाज सुनाई दे रही है
तो प्लीज चैट में रिप्लाई कीजिए कि आई एम
ऑडिबल और नॉट ऑडिबल प्लीज
ओके हेलो
प्लीज बताइए
जी जगत गुरु जी हर हर महादेव देव 822 हेलो
हैंड हैक अरवित हेलो थैंक यू सॉरी अगर आई
एम ऑडिबल तो थोड़ा सा वेट करते हैं
स्टूडेंट्स का तो तब तक के लिए आप मुझसे
डाउट पूछ सकते हो कि लास्ट क्लास में जो
भी कुछ हमने पढ़ा था क्या सबको क्लियर है
सबको क्लियर है सबको समझ में आ गया था
या कोई भी डाउट है आपका मुझसे पूछ सकते हो
क्योंकि आप नए हो तो कोई बात नहीं मैं
आपको बता देता हूं कि ये सीरीज काफी टाइम
से चल रही है और इस सीरीज की हमने
फ्रीक्वेंसी थोड़ी सी बढ़ा दी है अभी तो
इसके ऑलरेडी
52 लेक्चर्स हो चुके हैं आरवी शॉर्ट अगर
आपका जो भी नाम है इसके टोटल 52 लेक्चर्स
हो चुके हैं। यह सीरीज बेसिकली आपके एथिकल
हैकिंग की सीरीज है जिसमें आप ईजीपीटी
जैसे एग्जाम्स भी बहुत ही आसानी से दे
सकते हो और इस सीरीज में बहुत सारी चीजें
आनी बाकी हैं। तो इस सीरीज को हम काफी
लेवल तक इसको डिलीवर करने वाले हैं। तो
अभी यह हाफ में है। कंप्लीट सीरीज नहीं
हुई है। तो इसमें समय जरूर लगेगा। बट आपको
वह सारी चीजें देखने को मिलेगी जो आपको एक
पेड कोर्स में भी देखने को नहीं मिला था।
अगर आपको एथिकल हैकिंग या साइबर
सिक्योरिटी में अपना करियर बनाना है तो आप
एक काम कर सकते हो इस सीरीज को बिल्कुल
स्टार्टिंग से देख सकते हो और साथ के साथ
लाइव क्लास को कभी भी मिस मत कीजिए जिससे
क्या होगा कि हमेशा आपको आपको अपडेट मिलते
रहेंगे और हमेशा आप क्लास के साथ में चलते
रहेंगे
जोशी जी आप मुझे जब मैं Lindin देखता हूं
तभी मैं उस पे रिप्लाई करूंगा। अदरवाइज
नहीं कर पाऊंगा फिर मैं
ओके पुराने वीडियो देख लिए आपने अच्छी बात
है फिर तो आई होप सबको अच्छा लग रहा होगा
फिर सारी वीडियोस आपको समझ में आ रही तो
आज के सेशन को कंटिन्यू करें बताओ आज के
सेशन को कंटिन्यू
बताओ
बिल्कुल नमस्ते जी
चलो
हम यस हम इसको मिनिमाइज करते हैं नाउ
ऑलरेडी हम लैब से स्टार्टअप कर चुके हैं
और लैब स्टार्टअप से पहले एक छोटा सा
रिवीजन करते हैं कि कल के सीटीएफ में हमने
क्या-क्या किया था ताकि आपको पता चल जाए
कौन-कौन से स्टेप्स हमने परफॉर्म की थी और
उसके बाद कौन से स्टेप्स आज हम करने वाले
हैं।
देखो सबसे पहले हमने क्या किया था कि सबसे
पहले हमने स्टेप वन में रिकॉन किया था।
मतलब रिकॉन नहीं बोल सकते। स्कैनिंग और
एनुमिशन किया था। स्कैनिंग और
स्कैनिंग एंड एनुमिशन किया था जिसमें हमें
हमने मिला था
स्कैनिंग और एनुमिशन और उसमें हमें
क्या-क्या मिला था? स्कैनिंग और एनुमिशन
में थोड़े से स्पेलिंग मिस्टेक होते हैं
क्योंकि मेरा माइक बीच में आ रहा है। ओके?
स्कैनिंग और एनुमिशन हमने परफॉर्म किया
था। जिसमें हमें क्या देखने को मिला था?
स्कैनिंग एनिमेलेशन किया तो हमें कौन-कौन
से पोर्ट देखने को मिले थे? पोर्ट 13 9 और
44 45 और इवन हमें मिला था 3389 ये हमारे
इंटरेस्टिंग पोर्ट थे और जब हमने
स्क्रिप्ट स्कैन किया था तो स्क्रिप्ट
स्कैन करने के बाद यहां से हमें एक और
इंफॉर्मेशन मिली थी कौन सी इंफॉर्मेशन
मिली थी बता सकते हो वो इंफॉर्मेशन क्या
थी हमें इंफॉर्मेशन मिली थी कि इसके अंदर
एक वनेरेबिलिटी है इसके अंदर एक
वनेरेबिलिटी है इसके अंदर कौन सी वनबिलिटी
है इसके अंदर एमएस 17
ड 1 मतलब कौन सी वन
इटरनल ब्लू वलनेबिलिटी है जो क्योंकि ऊपर
से कौन सी वर्जन हमारा यूज़ हुआ था Windows
7 है क्योंकि यह हमारा कौन सा है? Windows
7 है। और SMB का कौन सा वर्ज़न यूज़ हो रहा
था? क्योंकि जो हमने SMB एनमरेशन परफ़ॉर्म
किया था इसके अंदर। क्योंकि स्टेप टू में
हमने क्या किया था? ये चीज तो हमने
स्क्रिप्ट के थ्रू कंफर्म कर ली थी।
कंफर्म करने के बाद स्टेप टू में हमने
क्या किया था? एसएमबी एनुमिशन किया था।
एसएमबी एनुमिनेशन किया था। वहां पर हमें
क्या मिला था? हमें मिला था कि एनोनिमस
अनोनिमस एक्सेस
हमें ग्रांटेड है। एक्सेस अलव है। बट
बट
बट क्या था?
शेयर अलाउड नहीं थे।
शेयर्स
एक्सेस नॉट अलाउड।
ओके? शेयर एक्सेस अलाउड नहीं थी। ओके? यह
चीज हमें क्लियर हो गई थी क्योंकि हमने
काफी
डीप में एसएमबी एनुमिशन परफॉर्म किया था।
उसके बाद हमने क्या किया? उसके बाद हमने
परफॉर्म किया था।
उसके बाद स्टेप थ्री में हमने क्या किया
था? स्टेप थ्री में हमने एमएसएफ कंसोल के
थ्रू एक्सप्लइटेशन किया था। हमने किस केस
किया था?
कंसोल एमएसएफ जो कंसोल उसके थ्रू हमने
क्या किया था? एक्सप्लइटेशन
एक्सप्लइटेशन परफॉर्म किया था और इनिशियल
एक्सेस हमने लिया था। इनिशियल एक्सेस गेन
किया था। हमने क्या किया था?
इनिशियल एक्सेस गेन किया था। और जो यूजर
हमें मिला था वहां पर इनिशियल एक्सेस में
हमें मिला था एंटी अथॉरिटी
एंटी अथॉरिटी सिस्टम हमें देखने को मिला
था। बट एक्चुअल में एंटी अथॉरिटी सिस्टम
नहीं है यह क्योंकि यह भी प्रोटेक्टेड
एनवायरमेंट है। स्टेप फोर हमने क्या किया
था? स्टेप फोर में हमने क्या किया था कि
स्टेप फोर में लोकल एनुमिशन किया था हमने।
लोकल एनुमरेशन
और लोकल एनुमिशन परफॉर्म करने के बाद हमने
देखा था कि
यह एंटी अथॉरिटी सिस्टम जरूर है बट इसका
टोकन कौन सा है? इसका टोकन कौन सा हमारा?
मिड एमआई लेवल टोकन था इसका। एमआई लेवल
टोकन था। मतलब हाई इंटीग्रिटी लेवल टोकन
नहीं था और इसके प्रिलजेस भी बहुत कम थे।
यह सारे स्टेप हमने परफॉर्म किए थे। सबको
याद होगा। सबको पता है। ये सारे स्टेप्स
हमने कल की क्लास में परफॉर्म किया था जो
भी कल की क्लास में थे। अगर ये सारे
स्टेप्स कल की क्लास में परफॉर्म किए थे।
तो ये चीज आपको क्लियर है। उसके बाद हमने
क्या किया था? था स्टेप फाइव में स्टेप
फाइव में हम हमने क्या किया था कि हमें
इनिशियल एक्सेस मिल गया और एंटी अथॉरिटी
सिस्टम हमें मिला मतलब हमें एडमिन एक्सेस
है एक प्रकार से लेकिन वो भी कंट्रोलोल्ड
है तो हमें क्या करना है प्रिविलेज
एस्केलेशन करने की जरूरत नहीं है हमें
प्रिविलेज एस्केलेशन करने की जरूरत नहीं
है लेकिन हमने क्या किया था क्रेडेंशियल
डंपिंग
क्रेडेंशियल डंपिंग की थी किसकी हेल्प से
क्रेडेंशियल डंपिंग की थी हमने किसकी
हेल्प से मिमी कैड्स की हेल्प से मिमी
कैट्स की हेल्प से हमने क्रेडेंशियल
डंपिंग की थी। मिमीट्स या मिमीट या हम बोल
सकते हैं कि केवी जो मीटर मीटर प्रेटर का
जो आपका
मीटर प्रेटर के अंदर आपका जो केवी मॉडल्स
है उसका हमने क्या किया था
मीटर प्रेटर के अंदर जो आपका केवी मॉडल्स
है उसको लोड किया था और उससे हमने क्या
किया सेम फंक्शन हमने अपने हैश डंप किए थे
जब हमने हैश डंप किए थे ठीक है? जब हमें
हैश डंप कर लिया था। स्टेप सिक्स में हमें
क्या मिल गया था? अपने हैशेस मिल गए थे।
किसका हैश मिला था? एक तो
एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर।
एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर का हैश मिला था। कौन सा
मिला था? एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर का एंटीएलम हैश।
एंटीएलम#श हमें मिल गया था। उसके बाद
दूसरा किसका मिला था हमें? दूसरा हमें
मिला था किसका? जोन का जोन का हमें
एंटीएलम#श मिला था। यहां तक हमने कर लिया
था। यहां तक हमने कर लिया था।
यहां तक हमने कर लिया था।
यह कोर्स बिल्कुल फ्री है। चिंता करने की
जरूरत नहीं है। बस इसका क्या होगा कि कुछ
टाइम के बाद हम एग्जाम इसको भी हम एक लेवल
पे सेटअप करेंगे। इसका पेड एग्जाम लेंगे
और आपको सर्टिफिकेशन मिलेगा। वह एग्जाम
आपको क्लियर करना होगा क्योंकि कोर्स तो
हम फ्री पढ़ा रहे हैं। आपका एक भी पैसा
नहीं ले रहे और जो एग्जाम होगा बिल्कुल
बेसिक अमाउंट होगी जिससे आप क्या कर सकते
हो? बिल्कुल एक प्रोफेशनल लेवल फुल
प्रैक्टिकल एग्जाम आपको देना होगा और उस
एग्जाम के बाद आपको एक सर्टिफिकेशन मिलेगा
और आप उसको यूज़ कर पाओगे।
ओके गाइस तो चलिए स्टेप सिक्स तक हमने कर
लिया था। तो स्टेप्स तो एक काम करते हैं।
अभी हम मशीन को ऑन कर लेते हैं और ट्राईक
के सर्विस से इसको कनेक्ट करते हैं। उसके
बाद हमारा नेक्स्ट स्टेप है वह हम आपको
एक्सप्लेन करने वाला हूं। स्टेप फोर और एक
काम कर देते हैं। तो इज़ माय यह रहा ट्राई
एकमी सर्वर। यह इसका IPपी एड्रेस है। और
चलिए हम अपने मशीन के अंदर चलते हैं।
थोड़ा ज़ूम कर देता हूं। तो सबसे पहले हम
क्या करते हैं? अपने डेस्कटॉप के अंदर
चलते हैं।
थोड़ा समझ मुझे लग रहा है कि हैंग आउट
करने वाला तो हम इसको परफॉर्मेंस लेवल पर
डाल देते हैं। सो दैट कि मशीन में कोई भी
प्रॉब्लम क्रिएट ना हो। उसके बाद लिस्ट
आउट करते हैं और शूडो करके हम ओपन वीpए के
थ्रू कनेक्ट करते हैं ट्राईक के सर्वर के
साथ।
ओके नाउ वी आर सक्सेसफुली कनेक्टेड टू
ट्राई हैक सर्वर नाउ अभी अब एक बार क्रॉस
चेक कर लेते हैं कि सब कुछ सही है बिल्कुल
सब कुछ सही है तो अभी हमें दोबारा क्रॉस
चेक कुछ करने की जरूरत नहीं है तो IPपी
एड्रेस मेरा कौन सा था टारगेट IPपी एड्रेस
यह मेरा टारगेट IPपी एड्रेस है। तो इसको
एंटर कर देते हैं। कोई प्रॉब्लम नहीं है।
तो अभी हम क्या करते हैं? डायरेक्टली अपना
एक्सेस गेन कर लेते हैं। तो एक्सेस गेन कर
लेते हैं। एक काम किसके थ्रू करते हैं हम?
अपने एमएसएफ के थ्रू।
ओके सर्विस हमारी स्टार्ट हो रही है पोस्ट
ग्री एसक्यूएल की। उसके बाद हम क्या कर
रहे हैं? एमएसएफ कंसोल को स्टार्ट कर रहे
हैं। हमने एमएसएफ कंसोल को स्टार्ट कर
दिया ताकि आपको सब कुछ दिखाई दे।
किसको मैसेज कर रहे हो यार?
अभी एक काम करते हैं हम सर्च करते हैं
अपने एक्सप्लइट को।
काफी अच्छा सीखा है अक्ष से आपने
और
थैंकफुल टू योर पेरेंट्स कि उनको उन्होंने
आपको बहुत अच्छे से संस्कार दिए हैं। बहुत
अच्छी सी चीजें आपने सीखे हैं। और मैं
उनको
अह अपनी तरफ से गुड इवनिंग या नमस्कार
कहना चाहता हूं कि आपका जो लड़का है वह
कामयाब हो रहा है धीरे-धीरे अच्छे-अच्छे
काम कर रहा है। तो आई होप कि आप यह
कमेंट्स हैं जो आप बोल रहे हो यह सारी
चीजें आप अपने पेरेंट्स को दिखाइए। आपकी
जो प्रोग्रेस है वो चीज आप लोग दिखाइए।
शायद वह भी खुश होंगे। प्राउड करेंगे आप
पर कि हमारा बेटा कितने अच्छे चीजें सीख
रहा है और यह कितने अच्छे काम कर रहा है।
शायद बहुत ज्यादा उनको प्राउड होगा। तो
जल्दी से आप यह कमेंट उनको भी दिखाइए
अच्छा रहेगा। ओके
चलिए तो हम एक काम करते हैं। अभी सेट कर
देते हैं अपने।
सेट कर दिया।
मीटर प्रिटर सेशन गेन कर लेता हूं।
चलो यहां पर हम चेक कर लेते हैं। ओके सब
कुछ सेट है तो हम इसको रन कर देते हैं।
आगे किसी ने और कोई कमेंट किया ही नहीं।
अच्छी बात है। तो अभी हम चेक करते हैं
क्या हमें इनफो गेट यूआईडी
तो गेट यूआईडी एंटी अथॉरिटी सिस्टम सेम
जैसे हमने देखा था गेट प्रीव्यू
गेट प्रिलजेस गेट प्रीव्यू्स यह देखिए
हमारे पास प्रिलजेस नहीं है। अब एक काम
करते हैं हम यहां देखते हैं प्रोसेससेस
कौन-कौन सी रनिंग है। दीज़ ऑल आर द प्रोसेस
दैट आर रनिंग ऑन दी सिस्टम। तो हमें क्या
करना होता है बेसिकली कि हमें
माइग्रेट करना होता है किसी मोर स्टेबल
प्रोसेस पर बट वी आर नॉट एबल टू माइग्रेट
क्योंकि यहां पर कुछ बहुत ही ज्यादा
लिमिटेशंस है इसको हम माइग्रेट नहीं कर पा
रहे हैं तो माइग्रेट करने की कोशिश करेंगे
तो यहां पर आपको एरर देखने को मिलेगी
माइग्रेट करो आप किसी भी प्रोसेस पे जैसे
कि फॉर एग्जांपल्स हमारी जो प्रोसेस होगी
मैं इस पे माइग्रेट करने की कोशिश करता
हूं सभी प्रोसेस पता कर नहीं सकते बट वी
कैन ट्राई ऑन इट वन प्रोसेस इज़ वन 328 8
हम इसको मैगनेट करने की कोशिश करते हैं।
तो ऑलरेडी 1328 से ही हम कनेक्टेड हैं।
बाकी 1528 से देख सकते हैं कनेक्ट होने की
15 28 हिट एंटर और आई थिंक वी आर नॉट एबल
टू यस ऑपरेशन फेल। और एक कमांड और होती है
अगर आपको क्या करना हो कि अगर आपको है एक
हैश डंप भी कमांड होती है#श डंप जैसे आप
हैश डंप करोगे तो हैश डंप आने चाहिए मतलब
यहां पर लिमिटेशन आप इसको रन नहीं कर पा
रहे लेकिन आपके पास ऑलरेडी हैश है जैसे कि
लोड कीवी मॉड्यूल करोगे आप लोड कीवी आपने
कीवी मॉड्यूल को लोड किया और एलएसए डंप
करोगे तो वहां से आपको सारे हैशेस मिल
जाएंगे तो यह चीज यहां तक हमने कल किया था
और उसके बाद हमें डिस्कस डिस्कशन करना है
कि बेसिक जो आज हमारा मेन टॉपिक है वो
डिस्कस करना। तो अगर हम इसकी हेल्प फाइल
देखें तो देख सकते हैं हम एलएसए डंप सेम
डेटाबेस को डंप करते हैं और हमारे पास वो
आ जाएंगे आपके एंटीएलएम हैज़ पे हमने कर
दिया। तो यह हमारे यह हमारा क्या है? आपका
एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर्स के एंटीएलएम हैश है और
आपका जोन का एंटीएलएम हैश है। अभी
बात करते हैं नेक्स्ट क्या? अब बात करते
हैं हम नेक्स्ट क्या होगा? नेक्स्ट का
मतलब है कि अब हमने क्या कर लिया कि वी
हैव ऑब्टेंड एंटीएलएम हैज़। नाउ व्हाट कैन
वी डू विद देम अपार्ट फ्रॉम क्रैकिंग।
मेरा मतलब यह है कि हमने टारगेट मशीन से
एंटी एलम पासवर्ड पासवर्ड के हैक्स को
एक्सट्रैक्ट कर लिया। अब सवाल यह उठता है
कि इन हैसेसिस को क्या सिर्फ हम क्रैक ही
कर सकते हैं या उसका और भी कोई पावरफुल
यूज़ कर सकते हैं। अगर हम पेंटेस्टर पॉइंट
ऑफ व्यू से बात करें एंटीएलएम हैश का
मिलना यूजरनेम और पासवर्ड के मिलने जैसा
ही बिल्कुल सेम होता है। मतलब अगर आपको
एंटीएलम हैश मिले या यूजरनेम और पासवर्ड
मिले बिल्कुल ही सेम है दोनों चीजों का
मिलना। तो क्यों इसका सवाल का जवाब मैं
आपको देने वाला हूं कि बट सबसे पहले मेरा
सवाल वही है व्हाट कैन वी डू विद दिस हैस?
इन हैसेसिस के साथ हम क्या कर सकते हैं?
बताइए आप इन हैसेसिस के साथ हम क्या कर
सकते हैं? किसी को कोई भी आईडिया है तो वह
मैसेज कर सकता है ग्रुप के अंदर अभी चैट
में। जल्दी से बताइए कमेंट में
क्योंकि हमारे पास एंटीएलएम हैश आ गए तो
क्रैक करने के अलावा और कौन सा पावरफुल
यूज़ केस है जो हम उसके ऊपर परफॉर्म कर
सकते हैं या कौन सा पावरफुल यूज़ केस हम
अप्लाई कर सकते हैं? क्या हम कर सकते हैं
क्रैक करने के अलावा उस इन एंटीएलम हैस के
साथ? मुझे अभी क्रैक नहीं करना बट मुझे यह
जानना है कि और क्या कर सकते हैं हम?
बताओ।
कोई भी बताना चाहेगा?
कोई भी स्टूडेंट्स कमेंट करना चाहेगा कि
हम क्या कर सकते हैं?
कोई भी स्टूडेंट्स रिप्लाई करना चाहेगा?
आई एम वेटिंग फॉर योर रिस्पांस।
फ्रेंड्स मैं आपके रिस्पांस का वेट कर रहा
हूं। तो प्लीज कोई भी बताना चाहेगा कि हम
क्या कर सकते हैं।
अकाउंट लॉग इन कैसे करोगे? बात तो वही है।
नो आईडिया।
हम परफॉर्म करेंगे पास द हैश अटैक। यानी
हम एक अटैक परफॉर्म कर सकते हैं जिसका नाम
है पास द हैश अटैक। इस अटैक का आईडिया
बिल्कुल सिंपल है। पासवर्ड की जगह
डायरेक्टली हैश को यूज़ करो ऑथेंटिकेशन के
लिए। समझ में आया? पासवर्ड की जगह
लिए। अब एग्जैक्टली मैं आपको समझाता हूं
कि पास द हैश अटैक का मतलब क्या होता है?
एक्चुअल में यह होता क्या है? इसके बारे
में हम डिस्कस करते हैं। ओके? तो, मैं
इसके बारे में आपको बताता हूं। पास द हैश
अटैक के बारे में। चलिए, हम एक काम करते
हैं। अपने नोट्स के ऊपर चलते हैं और पास द
हैश अटैक के बारे में आपको डिस्कशन करता
हूं। यह रहा हमारा पास द हैश अटैक। यह
हमारा पास द हैश अटैक। के बारे में कुछ
नोट्स मैंने आप लोगों के लिए लिखे हैं। यह
रहा।
पास द हैश इज एन एक्सप्लइटेशन टेक्निक दैट
इनवॉल्व्स कैप्चरिंग और हार्वेस्टिंग
एंटीएलम हैशेस और क्लियर टैक्स पासवर्ड
एंड यूटिलाइजिंग देम टू ऑथेंटिकेट विद द
टारगेट लेजिटमेटली ऑथेंटिकेट
वि द टारगेट टू लेजिटमेटली
पास द हैश अटैक अटैकर्स की एक ऐसी टेक्निक
होती है जिसमें कुछ स्टेप्स परफॉर्म किए
जाते हैं। कौन-कौन से स्टेप्स परफॉर्म किए
जाते हैं, मैं आपको बताता हूं। कुछ
स्टेप्स परफॉर्म किए जाते हैं। कौन-कौन से
स्टेप्स हैं? जिसमें स्टेप वन होता है
आपका स्टेप वन होता है आपका एंटीएलम
हैश को कैप्चर करना। एंटी एलएम#श
को#श
को
कैप्चर करना। किसके द्वारा? या तो वाया
वाया मेमोरी
मेमोरी में मिमी कैड का यूज करके मेमोरी
में क्या है मिमी कैट का यूज करके
मिमी कैट का यूज़ करके या फिर आप क्या कर
सकते हो वाया सेम डेटाबेस या आप सेम
डेटाबेस को डंप कर लो अगर आपके पास उस
प्रोसेस का एक्सेस है तो आपके पास इतने
प्लेजेस है तो सेम डेटाबेस को डंप कर सकते
हो इफ यू हैव दैट टाइप लेवल ऑफ प्रिविलजेस
अगर उस लेवल के पिलेजेस है या आप क्या कर
सकते हो एलसास प्रोसेस
जो है एलएस प्रोसेस को है उसको एक्सप्लइट
कर सकते हो या उससे डाटा एक्सेस कर सकते
हो या फिर आप क्रेडेंशियल डंपिंग करके बाय
डंपिंग क्रेडेंशियल
क्रेडेंशियल डंपिंग करके भी आप क्या इन
तीन चार तरीकों से क्या कर सकते हो आप
एंटीएलम हैस को कैप्चर कर सकते हो स्टेप
टू में क्या करोगे आप स्टेप टू जो आपका है
स्टेप टू में आप क्या करोगे स्टेप टू में
आप
डायरेक्ट इन हैश को ऑथेंटिकेशन के लिए यूज़
करोगे डायरेक्टली
एनtएलएम हैश फॉर ऑथेंटिकेशन
आपको ऑथेंटिकेशन के लिए डायरेक्टली यूज़
करना है। स्टेप थ्री में क्या होगा? स्टेप
थ्री क्या है कि अब स्टेप थ्री में आपका
जो Windows मशीन है या आपका जो सिस्टम है
सिस्टम को लगता है कि आप वो एक ओरिजिनल
यूज़र्स हो क्योंकि
Windows का जो ऑथेंटिकेशन प्रोटोकॉल है जो
Windows का जो ऑथेंटिकेशन सिस्टम है वह
हमेशा पासवर्ड की जगह हैश को ही वेरीफाई
करता है। क्योंकि सिस्टम सोचेगा कि आप एक
आप क्या है? एक वैलिड यूजर हो। एक वैलिड
यूजर हो। क्यों? बिकॉज़ क्योंकि जो Windows
का ऑथेंटिकेशन प्रोटोकॉल है,
ऑथेंटिकेशन
सिस्टम है, वह हमेशा क्या करता है? हमेशा
क्या करता है?#श
को ही वेरीफाई करता है। ओनली हैश वेरीफाई
करता है। दैट इज व्हाई आप क्या कर पाते
हो? पास द हैश अटैक परफॉर्म कर पाते हो।
इसलिए क्या होता है कि अटैकर्स बिना
पासवर्ड क्रैक किए भी एडमिन लोकल एडमिन या
डोमेन एडमिन बन सकता है। और पास द हैश
अटैक परफॉर्म करने के लिए आपके पास बहुत
सारे टूल्स होते हैं। लेकिन उनमें से दो
मोस्ट पॉपुलर टूल्स हैं। जिसमें पहला है
आपका मेटास्प्लर्ट पीएस एक्सेक मॉड्यूल।
दूसरा आपका क्रैक मैप एक्सेक। दूसरा है
आपका क्रैक मैप एकक। अब पार द हैश अटैक
मॉडल्स में क्या है कि आप डायरेक्टली एंटी
एलम हैश प्रोवाइड कर सकते हो पीएस एक्सक
क्या करेगा उस हैश को एसएमबी के थ्रू पास
करेगा और टारगेट सिस्टम पर क्या करेगा
एडमिन राइट्स के साथ आपको एक्सेस ग्रांट
करवाएगा आपको एक्सेस प्रोवाइड करेगा मतलब
आपको रिमोट मशीन के ऊपर वो भी मीटर
प्रिंटर सेल के अंदर हैश हैश के तरह हैश
के साथ क्या करा उस एंटीएलम हैश के थ्रू
आप सेम सेम एडमिन लेवल के एक्सेस गेन कर
पाओगे। दूसरा क्रैक मैप एक्सेस क्या है?
जो सीएमई है जो क्रैक मैप एक्सेस जिसको हम
सीएमई बोलते हैं जिसको हम सीएमई भी बोलते
हैं कि यह रेड टिमर का फेवरेट स्विस आर्मी
नाइफ टूल है। इसके थ्रू भी आप क्या कर
सकते हो? बिना पासवर्ड के हैस के थ्रू
एक्सेस ले सकते हो। बिना पासवर्ड के के
थ्रू हैस के थ्रू आप क्या कर सकते हो?
एक्सेस ले सकते हो। ओके? तो यह चीज आपको
समझ में आ गई। तो दिस टेक्निक विल अलव अस।
मैं आपको थोड़ा सा और ऊपर कर देता हूं।
वेट वेट
दिस टेक्निक विल अलाउ अस टू ऑब्टेन एक्सेस
टू द टारगेट सिस्टम वाया लेजिटमेट
क्रेडेंशियल एज अपर्स टू ऑब्टेन एक्सेस
वाया सर्विस एक्सप्लइटेशन।
ओके? कि मतलब यह है कि आपको कोई एक्सप्लइट
यूज करने की जरूरत नहीं है। आपको कोई
वनेबिलिटी नहीं चाहिए। ना ही आपको कोई बफर
ओवरफ्लो या आरसीई जैसे एक्सप्लइट की जरूरत
पड़ेगी टारगेट को एक्सेस करने के लिए। समझ
में आ गया? तो इस केस में क्या होगा कि बस
आपको क्या चाहिए? एंटीएलम हैश चाहिए और आप
एक लीगल क्रेडेंशियल्स का यूज करके मशीन
के अंदर एक्सेस गेन कर पाओगे। अब इससे
Windows को लगेगा कि यूज़र्स ने सही हैश
प्रोवाइड किया है। मतलब उसके हिसाब से
यूजर जो लॉगिन कर रहा है वह एक लेजिटमेट
यूजर है। इसलिए जो पास द हैश अटैक एक
पावरफुल
अटैक होता है और खासकर क्लैटरल मूवमेंट्स
के लिए इसका ज्यादातर यूज़ किया जाता है।
क्योंकि ना तो इसके लिए आपको पासवर्ड
क्रैक करने की जरूरत। ऊपर से आपको
लेजिटमेट ऑथेंटिकेशन के साथ एक्सेस मिलेगा
और रिमोटली आप एक्सेस कर पाओगे। सिर्फ
एंटी अलम#श का यूज करके। अब
जब भी आप पेनिट्रेशन टेस्टिंग करोगे आप एक
चीज नोटिस करोगे कि एंटी हेलम हैस जो आपको
मिलेंगे उनकीेंस उतनी ही ज्यादा या उतनी
ही पावरफुल है जितनी एक क्लियर टेक्स्ट
पासवर्ड की है। क्यों? क्योंकि Windows
ऑथेंटिकेशन सिस्टम एट द एंड क्या करता है?
आपके#श को ही वेरीफाई करता है। अभी
ऑब्वियसली एक चीज तो क्लियर है कि जो अगर
आपको क्लियर टेक्स्ट पासवर्ड मिल जाएगा तो
आपके लिए बेस्ट रहेगा क्योंकि आप उसको
आरडीपी के लिए, वीपीए के लिए, वेब लॉगिन
के लिए या ईमेल्स के लिए या अगर एसएसएस
इनेबल तो इन सबके लिए थ्रू लॉगिन करने में
यूज़ कर सकते हो। लेकिन अगर आपको क्लियर
टेक्स्ट पासवर्ड नहीं मिलता तो आप हैश का
भी क्या कर सकते हो? एक बहुत ही पावरफुल
वेपन बनाकर यूज कर सकते हो अपनी मशीन के
अंदर। आप हैश को भी क्या कर सकते हो? काफी
पावरफुल वेपन के फॉर्म में यूज कर सकते
हो। तो मेरे कहने का मतलब यह है अगर आपके
पास एंटीएलम हैश है तो आप कभी भी उस हैश
का यूज करके टारगेट के अंदर आ जा सकते हो।
टारगेट के अंदर ऑथेंटिकेट कर सकते हो। पास
द हैश अटैक टेक्निक के जरिए। अभी एक सवाल
होगा आपके मन में या आप जो सोच रहेगे अगर
आप लोगों के मन में यह सवाल नहीं भी होगा
तो मैं पूछ लेता हूं कि आप लोग पूछोगे सर
अगर मुझे एक बार एडमिन एक्सेस मिल गया तो
फिर मैं दोबारा से क्यों ऑथेंटिकेट करूं
उस मशीन के अंदर जब मुझे एक बार
एक्सप्लइटेशन के थ्रू एक्सेस मिल गया क्या
जरूरत पड़ी मेरे को दोबारा से उसके अंदर
एक्सेस लेने की यह काफी इंपॉर्टेंट सवाल
है लेकिन इसका जवाब मैं आपको देना चाहूंगा
फॉर एग्जांपल्स
आपने क्या किया कि एक एक्सप्लइट के थ्रू
फॉर एग्जांपल यही एक एक्सप्लइट था आपका
कौन सा MS 701
जिसका नाम है इटरनल ब्लू एक्सप्लोइट इसके
थ्रू आपको क्या किया आपने एक रिवर्स सेल
ले लिया आपके टारगेट मशीन के अंदर वो भी
एडमिन एक्सेस अब आप सोचोगे कि यहां पर
आपका मिशन कंप्लीट और आपको दोबारा लॉगिन
क्यों करना अब
अब असली चैलेंज स्टार्ट क्या हुआ कि लेकिन
जब जो सर्विस सर्विस आपने एक्सप्लइट की थी
उसको क्या कर दिया उस कंपनी ने पैच कर
दिया या फिर एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर ने वह सर्विस
डिसेबल कर दी या फिर फायर ने वह पोर्ट
ब्लॉक कर दिया जिस पोर्ट से आपने
एक्सप्लशन
स्टार्ट किया था जिस पोर्ट से आपने एंटर
किया था उस केस में क्या हुआ एक्सप्लइट चल
नहीं रहा है पोर्ट ब्लॉक है सर्विस डिसेबल
है पैच इंस्टॉल हो गया तो फिर से वापस
एक्सेस आपको कैसे मिलेगा क्या कोई चांस है
फिर से एक्सेस मिलने का? लेकिन अगर वहीं
पर आपने अपनी ट्रेनिंग में सब कुछ डिटेल
में सीखा है तो अगर आप स्मार्ट थे, एक
स्मार्ट मेंटर से थे और आपको इस केस में
अगर आपने अपने एंटी एलम हैचिस को डंप कर
लिया तो फिर आप सेफ हो जाओगे क्योंकि यह
सब होने से आपको बिल्कुल भी कोई भी फर्क
नहीं पड़ता क्योंकि
जो मुझे करना है वह मैं कर पाऊंगा क्योंकि
मैं एंटीएलम हैश के थ्रू भी क्या कर
पाऊंगा? मशीन के अंदर एंटर कर पाऊंगा। भले
ही आपने उस पोर्ट को ब्लॉक कर दिया हो, उस
उस एक्सप्लइट को उस वनेबिलिटी को पैच कर
दिया हो या फिर एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर ने वह
एक्सेस डिनाई ही क्यों ना कर दिया हो।
क्योंकि आपके पास लेजिटमेट क्रेडेंशियल्स
हैं। लेजिटमेट हैस हैं। समझ में आया जो
चीज मैं आपको बताने की कोशिश कर रहा हूं।
एवरीवन क्लियर सबने यह बात बिल्कुल ध्यान
से सुनी या नहीं सुनी है बताओ।
बिल्कुल सबने ये बात बिल्कुल ध्यान से
सुनी।
बताओ बताओ बताओ जल्दी से बताओ सब ने इस
बात को ध्यान से सुना या नहीं सुना
बिल्कुल समझ में आ गया बिल्कुल क्लेरिटी
मिल गई
तो अगर सबको समझ में आ गया तो जल्दी से
फटाफट
यस या नो का आंसर कीजिए चैट में जल्दी से
जल्दी ओके जल्दी से जल्दी देखो स्क्रीन
ब्लैंक नहीं हुई थी मैं जस्ट आपको बता रहा
था बिल्कुल आपको सुनना था क्योंकि इस
चीजों के लिए मैंने अभी पीपीटी रेडी नहीं
की थी क्योंकि यह पीपीटी रेडी करने के लिए
है ही नहीं कुछ चार लाइन के लिए आपको मैं
क्या बताता
ओके तो अभी चलते हैं
अपनी टारगेट मशीन के अंदर।
तो, हमारे पास एंटीएलम हैश है। यह रहे
हमारे पास और इन एंटीएलम हैज़ को हम क्या
करते हैं? स्टोर करके रख रहे हैं। तो चलिए
हम एक काम करते हैं अपने फिर से ओपन करते
हैं और एंटीएलम हैश को हम कंपेयर यह स्टोर
कर लेते हैं।
यह आपके#श है।
दूसरा आपका यह रहा।
पेस्ट। चलिए तो जैसा कि मैंने आपको बताया
आप यूज़ कर सकते हो इन हैशेस का क्या करने
के लिए? क्रैक करने के लिए। तो अभी कौन सा
मॉडल मैंने आपको बताया था? इसको कंट्रोल Z
करते हैं हम। बैकग्राउंड करते हैं और पीSX
सर्च करते हैं हम पीSX।
पीएस एक्सक मॉडल को हम सर्च करते हैं और
जैसे हम सर्च करेंगे तो हम यूज़ करने वाले
हैं SMB PSX
वे psx यह रहा एक्सप्लइट Windows SMB पीSX
एक्सप्लोइट Windows SMB पीSX यूज़ 24
यूज़ 24
यूज़ 24 किया हमने और हम ऑप्शंस को चेक
करते हैं इसके अंदर अभी हम जैसे हम ऑप्शंस
को चेक करते हैं तो हमने देखा यहां पर कि
आर होस्ट एक तो सेट करना है आरप सेट है
हमारा डोमेन यह इट्स ओके एसएमबी पासवर्ड
और एसएमबी यूज़र्स यहां पर हम एंटी एलएमस
रख सकते हैं ऊपर से ये रहा तो चलिए हम एक
काम कर सकते हैं इसमें एल पोर्ट सेट
करेंगे और अके
हम हम और क्या-क्या करते हैं हम से सबसे
पहले सेट एल पोर्ट चेंज करते हैं सबसे
पहले एल
हम एक काम करते हैं एल आर होस्ट करते हैं
सबसे पहले
आर होस्ट क्योंकि मेरा टारगेट आईपी मुझे
रखना है और व्हाट इज द माय टारगेट आईपी
देखते हैं इसमें कुछ है नहीं इसमें टारगेट
आईपी नहीं है सॉरी
आर पोर्ट और हम क्या करते हैं अभी अपना
टारगेट आईपी कॉपी करते हैं यहां से यहां
पर हम क्या करेंगे पेस्ट टारगेट आईपी को
हमने यहां पर पेस्ट किया हो गया अब मैं
क्लियर कर देता हूं स्क्रीन को ताकि आप
लोगों बिल्कुल दिख जाए। तो ऑप्शंस हमने आर
होस्ट अपना सेट कर दिया है। यह रहा टारगेट
आईपी। अभी हमें क्या करना है? अभी हमें
क्या करना है? एसएमबी यूजर का नाम सेट
करना है। उसके बाद उसके उससे पहले एक हम
एल होस्ट को भी सेट कर लेते हैं। एल होस्ट
हमारा क्या है? ट्यून जीरो। चलिए उसके बाद
सेट आर पोर्ट। आर पोर्ट क्यों सेट करने
वाले हैं? क्योंकि हमें क्या करना पड़ेगा?
एल आर पोर्ट नहीं एल पोर्ट।
एल4 पोर्ट और अभी हम क्या करते हैं? 4423
हम सेट करते हैं। 4423 हमने सेट कर लिया।
देन एक बार इसको भी क्रॉस चेक कर लेते हैं
क्योंकि अभी तो काफी इंपॉर्टेंट चीज है
हमारे लिए। देन सेट एसएमबी यू यूजर। तो
अगर हमें यूजर मिला है कौन सा? सबसे पहले
एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर। तो हम चलिए यहां पर एक
काम करते हैं। एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर
क्या करना? कॉपी। यहां पर क्या करना है
आपको? पेस्ट। कॉपी एंड पेस्ट।
एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर आपने सेट कर दिया। अभी एक
और इशू है कि पासवर्ड के लिए आपको यहां पर
कॉम्बिनेशन देना है। कॉम्बिनेशन एलएम हैस
प्लस में एंटी एलम हैसिस का कॉम्बिनेशन
देना है आपको पासवर्ड के लिए। तो मैं आपको
एक पासवर्ड जो आपका बाय डिफ़ॉल्ट पासवर्ड
होता है। मैं एक फाइल सेव की हुई है। यहां
पर मैं एक काम करता हूं। इसको भी हमने सेव
किया है कहीं पर कि बाय डिफ़ॉल्ट जो नल
वाला जो एलम हैश है मैं वह आपको शो करता
हूं। तो वेयर इज़ माय#txt
ना
एक फाइल थी ओपन फोल्डर हमने कहां पर अपने
डेस्कटॉप के अंदर कहीं पर स्टोर किया
होगा।
पासxt नहीं चाहिए।
यह रहा यह रहा। तो यह जो है सीक्वेंस यह
हमारा
नल वाला जो एलएम है तो एक काम करते हैं।
मैं इसको अभी मिनिमाइज कर देता हूं और
इसको ओपन करते हैं हम दूसरे वाले।
यह रहा यह रहा। तो हमें किस सीक्वेंस में
देना है? एलएम#श आपको बता देता हूं मैं।
एलएम#
उसके बाद
कॉलन ये सेमी कॉलन उसके बाद आपको क्या
करना है? एंटी एलएम हैस यहां पर तभी यह
काम करेगा एंटी एलएम#श तो अभी हम क्या
करने हैं? यह हमारा एलएम#श है। और एंटी
एलएम हैस क्या है मेरा? यह रहा। इसको हम
क्या करते यहां पर सेट कर देते हैं
कॉपी और यहां पर रख देंगे पेस्ट। तो यह हो
गया हमारा और इसको हम क्या कर अभी कंप्लीट
को पेस्ट कर देंगे अपने उसके अंदर कॉपी
एंड पेस्ट। तो यहां पर हम सेट
एसएमबी
पास उसके बाद कंट्रोल शिफ्ट वी हमने इसको
सेट कर दिया। हमने सेट कर दिया। फिर से अब
ऑप्शंस को हम चेक कर लेते हैं। तो, हमने
ऑप्शंस को चेक कर लिया। तो, हमारा यह
कॉम्बिनेशन भी सेट हो गया। एक और चीज हमें
क्या करनी है? सेट टारगेट। हमें क्या करना
है? टारगेट सेट करना है। सेट टारगेट यह
देख सकते हैं। टारगेट में हम क्या-क्या
सेट करते हैं यहां पर? कमांड। हमें क्या
चाहिए? टारगेट से। तो, हम अभी टारगेट सेट
करेंगे। नेटिव अपलोड।
टारगेट सेट करेंगे हम नेटिव अपलोड और
क्लिपबोर्ड। हिट एंटर। तो हो गया हमारा
टारगेट भी सेट हो गया। तो टारगेट सेट हो
गया। अब मैं ऑप्शंस को चेक कर लेता हूं
पूरे। सारे जितने भी ऑप्शंस हैं नेटिव
अपलोड हमारा टारगेट पे सेट है। एलॉस्ट
एलपोट सब कुछ हमारा सेट है। तो अभी हमें
क्या करना है? सिर्फ इसको एक्सप्लइट करना
है। रन करना है। तो मैं इसको रन करता हूं।
देखते हैं कि यह काम करेगा या नहीं करेगा।
इसको रन कर रहा हूं। यह बोल रहा है नो
एक्सेस। यह एक्सेस नहीं मिला। क्योंकि यह
जो यहां पर डमी दिया गया है इसके अंदर।
किसके अंदर? आपके ब्लू मशीन के अंदर यह
काम नहीं कर रहा। यह काम नहीं कर रहा। तो,
इस केस में हमें क्या करेंगे? हम दूसरे
वाले को ट्राई करते हैं। एक और कॉम्बिनेशन
बनाते हैं। दूसरा कॉम्बिनेशन क्या है? जोन
वाला। तो, इसको ट्राई करके क्या? यहां पर
एक्सेस मिलेगा मुझे। कॉपी और यहां पर हम
क्या करते हैं? पहले
कॉलन के बाद पेस्ट। उसके बाद यह एज इट इज
रखते हैं हम। यहां पर
कंट्रोल सी और यहां पर इसके आगे कंट्रोल
वी। तो इसको हम सबसे पहले इसको चेंज करते
हैं।
कंट्रोल सी यहां पर हम क्या करेंगे? सेट
एसएमबी
पास
हिट एंटर यह कर दिया। सेट एसएमबी
यूजर क्या था? ज़ोन। यही था। बिल्कुल हम
चेक कर सकते हैं जोन था और यहां भी हम चेक
करते हैं अभी
ऑप्शंस तो बिल्कुल सही है तो अभी हम इसको
रन करके देखते हैं क्या यह काम करेगा
कनेक्टिंग टू द सर्वर
यस यह नो एक्सेस नो सेशन हुआ सेशन क्रिएट
नहीं हुआ बट यह क्या कह रहा है अपलोडिंग
सोड
एसएमबी द एक्सटर्नल कोड स्टेटस एक्सेस
डिनाइड एक्सेस डिनाई कर रहा है। मतलब
एक
एक काम और कर सकते हैं इसको हम। अह सेट
टारगेट करके अलग देखते हैं। सेट टारगेट
एंड
अगर यह काम नहीं करेगा तो हम दूसरा और भी
ऑप्शन हमारे पास।
कमांड हिट एंटर। अब रन करके देखते हैं।
अभी यह ठीक है। यह काम नहीं कर रहा। हम एक
काम करते हैं। तो
चलो, यह हमारा एक्सेस है। यह सेशन हमारे
पास। अभी दूसरा एक और काम कर सकते हैं।
क्या कर सकते हैं हम? क्रैक मैप एक्स का
यूज़ कर सकते हैं। क्रैक
मैप एक्सक्ट। अब यह टूल की खासियत यह है
कि आप इसमें ओनली आपको#श प्रोवाइड करना
है। अभी ये यहां पर इशू क्या है? देखो मैं
आपको दिखाता हूं रियल में क्या इशू है। तो
एसएमबी उसके बाद टारगेट आईपी एड्रेस।
टारगेट आईपी एड्रेस मेरा क्या है? यह रखते
हैं हम। यह रहा हमारा टारगेट आईपी। हमने
कॉपी कर लिया। मिनिमाइज किया। यहां पे
हमने टारगेट आईपी को पेस्ट कर दिया। मैं
इसको ज़ूम कर देता हूं। सबको दिखाई दे रहा
है? बिल्कुल बताइए। सबको दिखाई दे रहा है
यहां पर? किसी को कोई इशू नहीं है। यहां
पर हमने पेस्ट कर दिया। उसके बाद हमें
क्या करना है? हफन
यू हफन यू स्मॉल में जोन हमने जॉइन किया।
हफन एच लिखेंगे। हफन एच मतलब आपका एंटी
एलम हैश। तो मैं एंटीएलम#श को कॉपी करता
हूं यहां पर। ओनली डायरेक्ट आपको
एंटीएलएमएस प्रोवाइड करना है। कॉपी किया
और एनtएलएमएस यहां पर प्रोवाइड कर दोगे
आप। किसके अंदर? डबल कोट के अंदर।
एंटीएलएमएस आपने प्रोवाइड कर दिया।
यह एंटीएलम हैश प्रोवाइड। तो पहले हम
वेरीफाई करते हैं कि यह पासवर्ड काम कर भी
रहा है या नहीं कर रहा। तो हिट एंटर जैसे
ही हम इसको एंटर करते हैं तो देखो आप यह
बताएगा यह पासवर्ड सही है। यह एंटीएलम हैश
सही है। आपको देखोगे यह हैश सही है। बट
प्रॉब्लम क्या है कि देखो हम यहां पर क्या
कर सकते हैं? कमांड भी रन कर सकते हैं।
कैसे?
हफन x यूज़ करेंगे। स्मॉल x
स्मॉल x और उस केस के अंदर आप कमांड दे
सकते हो। कौन सा? हु एम आई और कमांड दे
सकते हो और एंटर कर सकते हो। जिसे आप चेक
कर सकते हो। एंड हिट एंटर किया आपने। बट
यह देखना अभी इसने कुछ भी रिजल्ट शो नहीं
किया क्योंकि
यहां पर आपका पासवर्ड और एंटी एलम है सही
है बट यह भी इस चीज के लिए इसने कंट्रोल
किया हुआ है पूरा लिमिट किया हुआ है इस
लैब को यह इससे ज्यादा कुछ करने देगा नहीं
अगर आप इसकी जगह इफ कॉन्फिग करने की कोशिश
करोगे या कुछ भी पीडब्ल्यूडी करो यह देखो
करके और एडमिन वाला इसमें काम करेगा
क्योंकि वो एंटीएलएमएस गलत है तो इस तरीके
से क्या कर सकते हो आप पास द हैश अटैक
परफॉर्म कर सकते हो तो पास पारदा हैश अटैक
सबको समझ में आया कि पारदा हैश अटैक हम
कैसे परफॉर्म कर सकते हैं गाइस यह चीज
सबको समझ में आई कि पारदा#श अटैक हम कैसे
परफॉर्म कर सकते हैं इन दो मॉड्यूल्स में
आप क्या कह सकते हो डायरेक्टली एंटी एलम
हैश का यूज कर सकते हो और फर्दर आप क्या
कर सकते हो अपना एक्सेस मेंटेन कर सकते हो
या क्या कर सकते हो लेटरल मूवमेंट कर सकते
हो यह चीजें मैं आपको सिखाऊंगा और मे बी
आपके लिए मैं फर्दर और भी कोई भी
सरप्राइज़ रख सकता हूं वह आपको अभी मैं
बताऊंगा नहीं बोलो सर आप तो ज्यादा बताते
बताते हो करते कुछ नहीं हो तो मैं ऐसा
नहीं चाहता। तो ये चीज़ आपको समझ में आ गई?
यह चीज़ क्लियर है? तो एक तो काम यह कर
सकते हैं। दूसरा हम क्या कर सकते हैं?
दूसरा हम दूसरा बताओ हम क्या कर सकते हैं?
यह तो चलो हमने कर लिया। दूसरा हम क्या कर
सकते हैं?
दूसरा हम क्या कर सकते हैं?
समझ में आ गया ये चीज? पास द हैश अटैक
क्या परफॉर्म? बिल्कुल छोटा सा अटैक है बट
हमें लगता है पता नहीं क्या कॉम्प्लिकेट
चीज थी। कुछ भी कॉम्प्लिकेशन नहीं था। तो
दूसरा हम क्या कर सकते हैं?
दूसरा बताइए जल्दी से हम दूसरा क्या कर
सकते हैं? पादा हेयर ट्रैक परफॉर्म कर
लिया। दूसरा हम क्या कर सकते हैं?
क्रैकिंग तो कर ही सकते हैं ना? बताइए।
क्रैकिंग कर सकते हैं। और क्रैकिंग के लिए
हम दो टूल्स का यूज़ कर सकते हैं। बताओ
कौन-कौन से टूल्स का यूज़ कर सकते हैं? अगर
हम क्रैकिंग कर सकते हैं, तो क्रैकिंग के
लिए कौन से दोद दो टूल्स का हम यूज़ कर
सकते हैं? इसके लिए यह भी बता दीजिए अगर
हम क्रैकिंग कर सकते हैं तो
क्रैकिंग के लिए कौन से टूल्स का हम यूज़
कर सकते हैं बताओ।
यस बिल्कुल एग्जैक्टली हैशकैट या जोन द
रिपर का हम यूज़ कर सकते हैं। तो हम क्या
करने वाले हैं आज? और एक और फॉर योर काइंड
इंफॉर्मेशन बिल्कुल ध्यान से सुन लीजिए कि
आपको है है कैट और जोन द रिपर की पूरी
डिटेल चीटशीट मिलने वाली है आर्टिकल्स के
अंदर। इतनी डिटेल चीटशीट लिखूंगा किसी ने
नहीं लिखी होगी। सबको चाहिए ना दोनों
टूल्स की
काफी डिटेल्स में और इफ पॉसिबल कि मैं
सिनेरियो के साथ आपको वो चिटशीट
मेंशन करूं कि आपकी प्रैक्टिस हो जाए। यह
चीज सबको चाहिए।
चाहिए तो जल्दी से चैट में बताओ।
चाहिए।
तो हम यूज़ करने वाले हैं जॉन द रिपर। हम
यूज़ करने वाले हैं जॉन द रिपर। जॉन द रिपर
यूज़ करने से पहले हमें एक काम करना है कि
जॉन द रिपर के लिए आपको एक सीक्वेंस फॉलो
करना है। मैं अभी इसको क्लोज करता हूं। यह
वाला सीक्वेंस आपको फॉलो करना है कि पहले
आपका यूजरनेम हो। आप यह कौन-कौन सा
सीक्वेंस फॉलो कर सकते हैं। मैं बताऊं।
आपके पास यूजरनेम कॉलन आर आईडी उस यूजर की
कॉलन एलएम#श फिर उसके बाद कॉलन एंटीएलएम#श
उसके बाद इस तरीके से यह फॉर्मेट आप फॉलो
कर सकते हो मैं आपको बता रहा हूं यह
फॉर्मेट आपको क्या कर सकते हो फॉलो कर
सकते हो इसलिए यूजरनेम हमारा
एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर्स है दूसरा जोन है आर आईडी
कहां से आएगी यह सबको पता है आर आईडी कहां
से आएगी क्योंकि आर आईडी हमारे पास है अगर
आप देखोगे
सेशंस वन हमने यूज़ किया और जब हमने लोड की
को यूज़ करने के बजाय हमने यह था डंप किया
था हमने एंटी एलम एसिस को डंप किया था अगर
आपको याद हो तो तो तो तो तो
जब हमने डंप किया था वहां पर हमें आर आईडी
मिली थी तो हमें एक काम करते हैं लोड
केवी
ओके
आई होप कि सिस्टम के साथ इशू ना हुआ हो यह
क्योंकि अदरवाइज मुझे ऑन ऑफ करना पड़ेगा।
आपको बता देता हूं कि जब आपने डंप किया था
तो वहां पर आपको मिल गया था यह। आरआईडी
वहां पर मेंशन था तो मैं अभी वही मान के
चल रहा हूं क्योंकि अभी यह टाइम आउट हो
गया। इसमें प्रॉब्लम क्रिएट हो गई है।
इट्स ओके। तो वहां पर आरआईडी मेंशन था तो
आपने यहां पर आरआईडी लिख लिया 500 उसके
एलएम हैस मैंने आपको बता दिया यह
स्टैंडर्ड फॉर्मेट होता है एलएम हैस उसके
बाद एंटी एलम हैस आपने कैप्चर कर लिया
उसके बाद तीन डॉट अप्लाई यह बेस्ट
प्रैक्टिस होती है इसको यूज़ करने की यह
सबसे बेस्ट प्रैक्टिस होती है पूरा यूज़
करने की अदरवाइज आप क्या कर सकते हो आप यह
भी कर सकते हो आप मैं आपको बता देता हूं
क्या और क्या-क्या कर सकते हो आप क्या कर
सकते हो यहां पर ओनली
यूजरनेम उसके बाद कॉलन उसके बाद एंटीएलम
हैश भी दे सकते हो। इससे भी आपका पारदा#श
अटैक परफॉर्म हो जाएगा। नहीं पारदा#श नहीं
आपका क्रैकिंग भी हो जाएगी या यह इतना भी
कर सकते हो तब भी चल जाएगा क्योंकि उसको
वो अपने आप डिटेक्ट कर लेगा। तो यह दोनों
चीज आप कर सकते हो। तो एक तो यही आपका जोन
जैसे आपका हो गया मैं आपको बता देता हूं।
यह रहा एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर
कंट्रोल सी
कंट्रोल वी उसके बाद यह रहा।
दूसरा आप यह भी कर सकते हो।
आपको बताता हूं कैसे होगा यह सब चीजें।
यह रहा। तो अभी हमें क्या करना है? सबसे
पहले एक फाइल में फाइल ओपन करनी है। उसमें
सेव करना है इसको। हम क्या कर रहे हैं?
कॉपी किया और कॉपी करने के बाद इसको मैं
अभी क्लोज कर देता हूं। यह रहा मेरा कॉपी
कर रहा हूं। कॉपी किया हमने। इसको मैं अभी
क्लोज कर देते हैं हम। और यहां पर हम क्या
करते हैं? विम विम के थ्रू हम एक फाइल और
करते हैं।
डॉटxt
ही एंटर किया हमने कंट्रोल शिफ्ट यहां पर
कर दिया v। यह कर दिया हमने। बिल्कुल सही।
और उसके बाद एस्केप
उसके बाद शिफ्ट के साथ राइट और क्विट कर
दिया हमने। अगर हम कैट करके
देखेंगे#txts.xt
ये रहे हमारे पास है। अभी हम क्या करते
हैं? जोन की हेल्प फाइल को देखते हैं। जोन
की हेल्प फाइल को देखते हैं। यह देखो ये
इसकी हेल्प फाइल है। यह सारे ऑप्शंस हैं।
इसके अंदर बहुत पावरफुल टूल है यह। जोन
यूसेज क्या है इसका? जोन ऑप्शंस पासवर्ड
फाइल्स। अभी यहां पर हम क्या करने वाले
हैं? सबसे पहले हमें देखना है कि फॉर्मेट
कौन-कौन से फॉर्मेट सपोर्ट करता है जोन
क्या तो उसके लिए हम यूज़ करेंगे जोन हफन
हम यूज़ कमांड कौन से हफन हफन लिस्ट इक्वल
फॉर्मेट्स
लिस्ट इक्वल फॉर्मेट्स ये देखो इतने सारे
फॉर्मेट सपोर्ट करता है जॉन द रिपर ये
सारे फॉर्मेट्स लगभग आपके
सारी मशीनंस इस फॉर्मेट को सपोर्ट करती है
तो ये इन सारे सारे फॉर्मेट्स को सपोर्ट
करता है। अब इसमें से मुझे अपना फॉर्मेट
फाइंड आउट करना है। तो हम यूज़ करेंगे गैब
कमांड।
गैब एंटी हम करेंगे हिट एंटर। तो अभी मुझे
क्या करना है इसमें? देखो कौन सा फॉर्मेट
सेलेक्ट करना है? मुझे एंटी फॉर्मेट
सेलेक्ट करना है। तो मुझे कैसे सेलेक्ट
करना है अटैक करने के लिए। तो हम यूज़
करेंगे जोन उसके बाद हफन हफन फॉर्मेट हफन
हफन फॉर्मेट। उसके बाद इक्वल एंटी लिखा।
कौन सा फॉर्मेट देन उसके बाद मुझे क्या
करना हैसtxt
ए एस ई एस
क्या फाइल का नाम क्या था उसका
फाइल का नाम था हमारा
यह रहा कॉपी सिलेक्शन
ये रहा कॉपी सिलेक्शन और इसको हम एक काम
कर देते हैं अभी
पता नहीं सब मेरा काली नेक्स ही हैंग आउट
करता है पता नहीं कैसा काली नेक्स यह यह
ग्राफिकल यूजर इंटरफ़ेस बहुत पहले नहीं
होता था। अभी के जो वर्जन सारे ग्राफिक
यूजर इंटरफ़ेस ऐसे ही हैंग आउट करते हैं।
किसी किसी के पास शायद कोई सशन हो तो
प्लीज मुझे बताओ।
अरे यार क्या इशू हो रहा है?
इसको नया टैब ओपन कर लेते हैं।
एलएस
के डॉट हम क्या करने वाले हैं? अभी
जोन हफन हफन फॉर्मेट इक्वल टू हम यूज़ करने
वाले हैं एनt उसके बाद H एस
estxt
यह हमने कर लिया उसके बाद देन आप क्या कर
सकते हो एक तो डायरेक्टली एंटर कर सकते हो
तो जोन की बाय डिफॉल्ट जो वर्ड लिस्ट है
यह उसका यूज़ करेगा ठीक है उस वर्ड लिस्ट
का क्या करेगा यूज़ करेगा उस वर्ड लिस्ट का
यह यूज़ करेगा दूसरा क्या कर सकते हो आप
दूसरा आप क्या कर सकते हो कि आप खुद की
वर्ड लिस्ट प्रोवाइड कर सकते हो। खुद की
वर्ड लिस्ट कैसे प्रोवाइड कर सकते हैं?
मैं आपको दिखा देता हूं। मैं पहले इसको एक
काम करता हूं। इसका रीनेम कर देता हूं।
इसको यह कैप्चर ही नहीं कर रहा। इसको
रिनेम ही कर देते हैं हम। वो भी दिखा देता
हूं मैं आपको। यह भी दिखा देता हूं।
यह हैंग आउट कर रहा है। अभी हैंग आउट नहीं
कर रहा। पता नहीं क्या इशू है इसका। मैं
सिर्फ क्रैकिंग दिखा रहा हूं। एक काम कर
इसकी हमें जरूरत ही नहीं है। इसको भी
स्टॉप कर देते हैं।
स्टॉप यार।
उसके बाद बाद हम यूज़ करने वाले हैं हाइप
विदाउट वर्ड लिस्ट हिट एंटर नो सच फाइल
एंड डायरेक्टरी ओके
आई होप यह सही होगा वही एंटर कर दिया हमने
ओके टीfmd5
लोडेड टू पासवर्ड हैस विद नो नो डिफरेंट
साल्ट नो पासवर्ड हैश लेफ्ट टू क्रैक
क्योंकि इस स्टेप पे हम क्राई कर चुके हैं
इसलिए क्या बोल रहा है यह इधर शो कर रहा
तो हम एक काम कर सकते हैं इसको जो
हफन हफन लिस्ट
एसिएस
कुछ एक पैरामीटर होता था तो आई होप कि कुछ
डिफरेंट हम इन्हें प्रोवाइड करें किसी को
याद है इसका एक कोई अगर हम चेक ऑफ लिस्ट
देखें जोन की तो हफन हफन लिस्ट हफन हफन
कुछ ऑप्शन होता है एक इसका
ऑप्शन होता है इसमें क्योंकि इसको हम
ऑलरेडी क्रैक कर चुके हैं तो इसको यह क्या
कर रहा है दोबारा शो ही नहीं कर रहा तो
क्रैक को हम देखने के लिए एक ऑप्शन होता
है इसमें कि हफन हफन शो फॉर्मेट नहीं एक
और किसी को याद है इसका ऑप्शन एग्जजेक्टली
अभी मेरे पास
तो मैं एक बार चेक करता हूं।
और हमने इसको ट्राई भी किया था बट इट इज
नॉट क्रैकिंग।
क्योंकि यह हम पहले कर चुके हैं। इसको
देखोगे फॉर्मेट एंटी#xt
मैं एक काम करता हूं। होम डायरेक्टरी के
अंदर मेरी एक
होम डायरेक्टरी के अंदर डेस्कटॉप
नहीं होम डायरेक्टर डाउनलोड
rq.txt मेरे पास
ext हिट एंटर किया। यह देखो
यस इट इज ट्राइंग टू
अभी ये क्या है हमने प्रोवाइड किया खुद के
वर्ड लिस्ट से यहां पर वर्ड ओके एक और
पैरामीटर यहां पर गलत दिया हमने हफन हफन
क्या प्रोवाइड करना था वर्ड लिस्ट मेंशन
करना था इक्वल और ये हमने गलत प्रोवाइड
किया तो एक काम करते हैं कंट्रोल सी करता
हूं मैं इसको और मैं फिर से इसको लिखता
हूं हूं। बहुत सारी गलतियां हो रही मुझसे
जोन हफन हफन फॉर्मेट इक्वल टू एंटी
कीबोर्ड का इशू हो रहा है मेरी तरफ से।
उसके बाद
ttxt hfन hfन
वर्ड लिस्ट इक्वल यह रही हमारी वर्ड लिस्ट
हिट एंटर। अभी इसने इसको क्रैक कर चुका
है। यह तो यहां पर यह आपको शो नहीं कर
रहा। लेकिन इसका पासवर्ड ऑलरेडी क्रैक कर
दिए थे इसने ओनली किसका जॉन का क्योंकि
एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर का पासवर्ड इस वर्ड लिस्ट
में नहीं था इसके मैच नहीं करे थे इसलिए
हुआ नहीं था तो यह आप भी खुद से भी कर
लोगे
क्योंकि यह अभी नहीं शो कर रहा मेरे केस
में नहीं शो कर रहा क्योंकि एक बार जो
क्रैश कर लिया हमने हो जाएगा यह कर लोगे
आप
यह खुद से आप कर लोगे
कितने स्टूडेंट्स हो यार आप लोग मैं आज
मैंने बैक टू बैक क्लास ली और आप लोग इतने
अच्छे हो ना मेरे लिए मोटिवेट करने के लिए
10 से 12 स्टूडेंट आते हो आप क्लास के
अंदर ओनली 10 10 टू 12 स्टूडेंट्स और आप
लोग मुझसे बोलते हो कि रेगुलर क्लास लो सर
और क्या किस लेवल पर आप लोगों को मैं
डिलीवर कर दूं आप डिर्व ही नहीं करते यार
आप लोग
मिस मुझे लगता है कि मैं रिग्रेट करने
वाला हूं क्योंकि दोबारा से मैंने कोर्स
अह स्टार्ट किया आप लोगों के जी
क्या हो यार तुम लोग?
एक और टूल पढ़ाने वाला था। अब मन नहीं है
यार।
आप लोगों के लिए आर्टिकल लिखता हूं। आप
लोगों के लिए सब कुछ प्रोवाइड करता हूं।
बदले में क्या मिलता है? कुछ नहीं।
कितने भी नहीं आते तुम लोग?
मैं जितने मुझे कितना हो गया इसको सिक्स
मंथ हो गया इस सीरीज को एटलीस्ट पढ़ाते
हुए सिक्स मंथ में खुद ही देखो आपकी ना तो
कोई इस पर कोई कोई स्टूडेंट बढ़ा है ना
कोई कम हुआ है
पता नहीं
चलिए फिर आज के सेशन को इधर ही एंड करते
हैं।
मेरे को बंद मशीन
क्या पढ़ाऊं आप लोगों को
मैं कितना एडवांस भी पढ़ाने का मैं सोच
रहा हूं कि आप लोगों को एडवांस पढ़ा दूं।
आप लोग नहीं हमेशा याद रखो मेरे को कि मैं
इतना एडवांस पढ़ा दूं। बट आप लोग भी चाहते
नहीं एडवांस पढ़ना। मैं बहुत कुछ प्लान
करता हूं। बट रियली
आप लोग नहीं चाहते सच में।
चलो फिर कुछ नहीं नो डाउट्स नो क्लास
बाय-ब गुड नाइट एंड सी यू फॉर नेक्स्ट
गाइस। बाय आज मैं नहीं बात करूंगा आप
लोगों से।
सीधी सी बात है। आप अपना काम कीजिए। मैं
अपना काम करूंगा। बेटर रहेगा।
क्यों मेरा भी टाइम वेस्ट करते हो? क्यों
अपना भी टाइम वेस्ट करते हो यार आप लोग?